we know a lot about or growing our our
knowledge about the effects of
meditation long-term meditation in
people like monks that meditate for 50
or you know 50,000 hours in their
lifetime and we know that this
completely changes the
electrophysiological responses of their
brains they have much higher levels of
what we call gamma waves which is a
particular frequency of wave not only
that but even their resting baseline
even when they're not meditating their
wave their brainwaves are more like
meditation the meditation kind of
brainwaves then then novice people that
don't have any experience meditating so
it really changes both the baseline
level of physiological activity as well
as the response when you're asked to
actually meditate there are kind of two
categories of studies that have been
done on meditation one on these lifelong
meditators the monks and the others on
the other category of studies on people
like you and me that that started out
with no meditation experience and
started to meditate and those perhaps
are more relevant studies for for most
people and those studies have shown
significant improvements in attention
functions with with increased exercise
and also actual anatomical changes in
the brain with perhaps a little bit more
experience with meditation maybe five
years of meditation experience increase
the size of white matter bundles in the
prefrontal cortex so there are you know
substantial physiological anatomical
changes that have been shown with with
meditation and there's also effects on
depressive symptoms so decreases of
depressive symptoms decreases in stress
symptoms so meditation is doing lots of
positive things in some very very
similar to exercise and some slightly
different so I think there's there's
definitely going to be a difference but
there's overlapping positive functions
that exercise and meditation have on on
your general brain health
how do you get to be a regular meditator
and the answer is I think start very
very small I know for myself I have a
sub chapter in my book called
confessions of a yo-yo meditator because
I think I have tried all different kinds
of meditation and my big mistake early
on was to try and meditate for too long
a Teta at a city so I would try and
meditate for 20-25 minutes with no
meditation experience and it was a
disaster I I forced myself to do it for
thirty days thinking that that would be
it and I would form my habit and day 31
I took a little break and they never
came back but then when I came back
again starting very very small with
things that that you know I can just do
on my own just breathing meditation
focusing on the breath something that we
all do at the end of yoga classes that's
what really kind of helped me build my
muscle and I just have to stick with
that very short meditation and build it
up that way and I think people too often
either start too long or don't stick
with it enough but again shorter is
better and I think that that is a that's
a key for for people that want to start
to meditate